by the way despondent me do you guys say
huge or huge as a huge you do New York
says huge they love that huge you say
huge we set huge say huge huge hard to
do isn't it for some reason unless you
grew up with it what if I say so oh my
god I think is huge people look at me
like I'm a [ __ ] psycho huge oh that's
[ __ ] huge you say you know Trump does
what you do Trump goes huge
yo yo know you you agree with 95 to 97%
of what he says and we talked about this
before does ya public public know you
would never tell the world how big of a
fan you are yeah ah not until now do you
think my hand is not going immediately
to the right in that voting booth in
November 2020 this is a this is terrible
but I open the show all weekend this
weekend and I said I said I would thank
you guys for coming out I don't know if
you guys are paying attention to what's
going on around the world right now
especially Australia it's very sad it's
heartbreaking so I want to let you guys
know I've decided tonight all the ticket
sales every single dollar tonight of
your tickets and people are already like
whoa and every single dollar was going
to Trump 2020 campaign yeah he's 2020
campaign whether you like him or not
you've invested you've invested isn't it
funny to [ __ ] with someone to take their
ticket sales and do that would be would
be wild if I did that show yeah and then
I and I'd list their names cuz they
bought it online I could list their
names that donated now man you decided
to pay me so I'm gonna donate this case
yeah I mean the crowd loved it they lost
it but then after what some one woman
was like are you really gonna donate
your ticket sales I was like no no what
are you out like so so [ __ ] dumb so
dumb yeah go to you after she after a
comedy show and ask if you meant
something or saying they're offended by
something it's almost like going into a
pizza store and going do you guys sell
you guys have pizza here I mean it's a
[ __ ] yeah it's insane if you're
taking anything literally you obviously
are missing we're at the store you're in
one percent this room for this with this
this woman said this weekend she goes
she asked I did a joke on on your mom's
house on cigars and I did it I did this
whole joke that I didn't I was paying
for another man's life and I was decided
that I was getting out of comedy and
getting into porn and I
to further my career as a pornographic
actor right yeah and she literally was
like I I thought you really were gonna
get into porn like I looked it up like I
didn't know do you were you do you plan
on really quitting comedy and I was like
ma'am don't ever come back to a show
please
don't if that's you if you have no idea
that that's an obvious joke like I get
scared when I say that stuff on a
podcast and people don't get it I'm just
like oh my god are we slipping away from
reality that far that they don't know
we've got I mean comedians like we were
talking about the other podcast it's
like you get sick held to the same
standard as a politician it's like it
says in my bio I'm a comedian everything
that you hear and see I'm [ __ ] I'm
[ __ ] around
yeah under attacking like that
I love the Ricky Gervais thing and I
also love Dave Chappelle's Twain's yeah
it was wonderful because when you have
the biggest dogs in the genre defending
the genre we're getting like can't say
that can't say that can't get this can't
do that don't do that don't do that
didn't that funny to think that the
previous the forefathers of comedy that
before us were way more [ __ ] up than
we ever were and that's the irony is
like now we're the bad guys for some
reason you're like are you kidding me do
you ever hear what Don Rickles used to
say you ever pay attention to anything
like I love when people say that they're
a fan of his and I was like really it's
the same way I feel about Howard Stern
like I have nothing but respect for
Stern but it is funny that there's all
these like super hardcore liberal
feminist activist Hollywood people that
go there he's the same guy who's like
how big is his dick you know I mean he's
like the first guy to be like the show
me your tits
you know I mean Gwyneth Paltrow let me
see your tits yeah it's so funny that
like wheat they hold everyone holds
everything to a difference and so you're
right when a big guy in comedy stands up
for the whole of us to be like you guys
can't you can't pick and choose you you
have to let this all exist you can't
just go they can say it because they're
more famous no [ __ ] that people are you
have to let it all exists when Chappelle
said that [ __ ] when he said I don't care
if I know he's racist and I disagree
with him I might still have a beer with
him afterwards it's just that's the
world of comedy that exists I was I
think that's that's what it always it's
what it used that's what that's what you
should be the norm and now it's like
this weird [ __ ] but [ __ ] all that [ __ ]
all that yeah I think I think now though
real comedy fans in my opinion are
solidified as
as the actual consumers of comedy more
than ever now it's not just a trend it's
not like I love comedy I think now more
than ever I see people it's like they're
all hardcore comedy fans that are coming
out they're like wanna be there bad
which is good it eliminates the [ __ ]
people that don't even want it you know
we just came here and we thought it was
you know whatever it's like me and we
didn't like the way he talked so I go
well [ __ ] don't come then well that's
what's beautiful about this is like this
unfiltered unedited comedy we can do
it's like we're in these people's ears
for like an hour a week and they're just
we feel like it's almost like we're a
part of their family
I'm inside your car yeah I'm inside
their car right let's say I'm inside
your car right now I'm inside your
[ __ ] 2013 Hyundai Sonata and I can
hear it that trunk is rattling right now
isn't it yeah yeah I hear you Mike I see
you driving alone on 185 I know what's
going on with you pal listen don't do it
put away the gun don't do it Mike or he
pulls over he's crying if you are gonna
do it I would livestream it oh yeah like
every man waits for your family